For many Americans, scenes from long conflict between the Israelis and the Palestinians...
...are all they know about Palestine and its people.
That's why the founders of the new Museum of the Palestinian People in Washington, DC.,...
...a space full of artwork, historical and cultural documentation, say...
...this place is so important.
We're showing Palestinians as human beings.
We're showing Palestinians as entrepreneurs.
We're showing Palestinians as artists.
And that's why I decided to create this museum.
So, it's a place where Palestinians can share their stories.
As visitors enter the museum,...
...the first piece they're welcomed by is a blue water pitcher.
It is made of glass from Hebron,...
...a city in the West Bank known for its glassblowing tradition.
The museum walls are covered by photos, paintings and other artwork,...
...telling Palestinian stories.
The founders are very aware that some might see this museum...
...in the politically-charged lens of the Palestinian-Israeli conflict,...
...but founder and workers here insist this is not about politics.
Bshara hopes the museum will attract visitors from all walks of life...
...and that it sparks a dialog about Palestinian history and its rich culture.
Imron Jadoon VOA News, Washington.